melvin landerneau à changer de braquet
maintenant ils roulent dans le sillage
de ses aînés à 20 ans mais l'une des
proches dans ticket pour les mondiaux et
x une bonne nouvelle lui espérait
vraiment faire partie du voyage
[Musique]
vous vivez performance on va dire oui et
non parce que c'était un peu mitigé sur
cette année mais j'ai montré des belles
choses sur les coupes du monde que ce
soit en vitesse par équipes où est mort
c'est une performance individuelle que
ce soit à l'entraînement ou en
compétition donc j'espérais vraiment
cette sélection
le martiniquais a brillé chez les jeunes
accroché à son tableau
un titre national et européen juniors
trois ans après cette inaction à
l'échelon supérieur est une suite
logique
levine ça c'est un gros potentiel il ya
une progression linéaire qui est un
petit peu lente par rapport à ce qu'on
attend de lui on espérait quand même
beaucoup plus mais voilà tout doucement
il ya des choses qui se mettent en place
maintenant on lui donne sa chance sur un
championnat du monde alors comme on l'a
dit avec des ambitions n'ont pas de
médaille mais vraiment de grandir et
voilà c'est fait partie des personnes
qui on croit beaucoup en l'absence de
grégory baugé toujours en selle melvin
landerne se sent en mesure de jouer les
trouble fête
il a une certaine latitude pour
apprendre encore plus le métier ça ne
fait pas vraiment j'ai mon personne ne
m'attend j'espère créer la surprise sur
sur ces championnats j'espère faire le
meilleur performance que jusqu'à
maintenant j'espère que je ferai
championnat et parce qu'on n'a aucune
aucune attente david moyes aucune
aucune crainte donc j'espère vraiment
surprendre tout le monde le maillage
entre les anciens et les nouveaux a bien
fonctionné avec melvin et les autres
l'équipe de france repart à la conquête
de nouveaux titres
la vie